when Henry Cavill walks through the
smoke and he says
I I like truth but I'm a big fan of
Justice favorite Justice League
I think he got a different kind makes me
laugh every time
I believe in truth I'm also a big fan of
justice but I'm a big fan of Justice I
wish you walked through and said that I
mean like oh [ __ ] this version no no no
no no what have we done that's Walter
ramada's like I was right I was right
that's the one right there we're gonna
meet halfway if you're gonna put
Superman in here
what's going on there citizens of the
reject Nation we are going to talk a
different kind of talk about the Black
Adam post credit scene I am of course
joined by the buffest man in the comic
book World Coy the man genre how are
your biceps they're doing okay you know
I uh interviewed The Rock and I felt
like a small child so I've been going
back extra hard and extra heavens and
trying to keep up it's a good good
interview you guys should watch us on
the Nerdist Channel he didn't want to do
it for our Channel I was like no no
specifically not the real rejects so uh
there's a short of koi's uh up here
where you can get his opinion on Black
Adam bottom line he liked quite a bit
and then you could watch our non-spoiler
review who I did with John a lesson
experience oh yeah it was all right
that's just where I landed I really
didn't expect to be as enamored with it
as I was and I'm happy you did and I've
been up editing way too late too often
this past week and a half to argue with
you on it so we were gonna do a heated
debate on the internals and Greg was
like I would like to sleep like you know
what I'd rather just just accept your
opinions and except that I enjoyed it
but the post-credits scene though that
is something that has been a massive
talk or something that seems like Dwayne
Johnson himself has really been wanting
to get the word out on there it seems
like he wanted it to leak you know and
that's what I find so fascinating about
it I want to go over our emotional
reactions to this and then I want to
talk about some of the lead up to it
because I feel like it's just been such
a fascinating journey of what's happened
specifically with this post-credits
scene so yeah real quick we got to go
over what happens in this post-credits
scene Black Adam he is now officially
back to being ruler of conduct looks
badass
um Walter Ramona I don't know it's
Amanda Waller yeah
a little tiny producers just like we
don't want him
he's not welcome here
three Superman spin-offs here's the
Headless Superman again
some sort of Superman spot I'm so
abandoned water shows up in a drone
Dwayne Johnson as Black Adam says
there's no one on this planet that can
stop me Amanda Waller replies I can call
in a favor send people who aren't from
this planet and then bring Green Lantern
shows of immersion
is everyone not from this planet after
the Dwayne Johnson says send them all so
after he destroys the Drone suddenly the
silhouette descends from the sky now
keep in mind like koi when you get into
his thoughts on his experience with it
because koi had not had it leaked for
him he saw it before a lot of other
people and I had had it leaked for me
before watching it like it was just
everywhere and there were some
journalists who like decided just screw
it I'm gonna lead with it and then
Dwayne Johnson wasn't helping either
like 20 shots it was like he's in it
don't worry he's gonna be in it but even
knowing Henry Cavill was gonna show up
with the original Superman John Williams
scores started playing I was like oh
this is still really exciting this is
still great then when he walks through
the smoke and then you see that he's got
a different kind of hair with a cool
little Superman curl and his suit looks
just so beautiful and Sleek walking
through and I think he says a line that
feels like a tad bit meta it's been a
while since anyone's made the world this
nervous I haven't put on this cape in a
long time
I definitely made a sound I'm
embarrassed retrograde flame remembering
when he comes through and you first see
his face because we've had so many
facelifts I think I was like oh like I
made like an excitable like this is
insane this is it was nuts the whole
time there was that rumor going around
for months but since it hadn't been
confirmed in any way you could feel the
credits are about to roll and then when
it happened I was
back to phase one Marvel I was like can
they do is it I was so emotional I got
back to that like oh my God they're
bringing in characters from multiple
franchises it literally felt like 2008
again where I was like they can do that
even though they've been doing it for 14
years since I didn't think we'd ever see
Henry Cavill again since I had kind of
like let the DC Universe Go I mean I
made a whole video here about what I
would do to relaunch the DC Universe and
it was largely wrap up the films you
have now keep a DC Black Label and then
recast the core players launching from
Shazam and Black Adam but that meant
recasting Henry Cavill as much as I love
him I just thought that's the way they
were gonna go so to be honest seeing him
on screen with that score in the perfect
suit so perfectly shot I felt like I did
when they first said The Avengers
Initiative yeah I fully felt that magic
and then that line I think is so great
because Superman made people nervous so
it kind of sounds like they should team
up oh that'd be cool versus them
fighting each other it does raise some
questions instead of bvs it's b-a-n-s
yeah
full circle well and I love that like we
also imply that she can call Superman
like that's really interesting too that
like Amanda Waller have any it's kind of
weird you know what I mean it's a bit
weird because like Amanda Waller having
dirt on Superman is interesting but
weird since she was always like when you
prepare for if there's a Superman out
here you know but we won't show him
because we can't show his face yeah this
is kind of weird that's refer to him a
lot Manuel could just call on Superman
but I also like the idea that Superman
is already like keeping an eye on Black
Adam so then it's just like okay you had
one chance to do it your way yeah I'm
gonna do it my way but I would love to
see any sort of interaction whether it
team up or fight and to be honest I
would personally rather it team up
between the two of them and and he's The
Reluctant foil because I if we have a
Black Adam versus Superman movie it
could easily be like Dragon Ball Z where
it's for two hours it'd be great
I would watch it I'd be excited about it
and you could lean into the anti-hero
stuff a bit more Zack Snyder could
direct a really good
Superman does he know Superman do things
I feel like yeah there's a lot of it
would destroy the world
no but I honestly I wonder what it would
look like to have Henry Cavill because
he's done so many other things outside
of Superman like would that movie Feel
Like a Rock movie or would it feel like
the Man of Steel flavor or would it feel
like you know going forward to the DC
Universe because this is a brand new
start effectively like we're changing
what DC films is is the the inevitable
you know the two of them is that gonna
Feel Like a Man of Steel too what if
Shazam 3 and Man of Steel 2 the black
Adam's Villain at both
the Rocks really controlling the DC
Universe he's the Thanos but he's like a
full-time yeah I'm the big villain and
I'm the big hero everywhere on Black
Adam everyone's always said Black Adam
should dominate the DC Universe this is
the hierarchy shift I demanded the Black
Adam everywhere but no I think it's
really interesting that we're getting
more of the Old Guard kind of when they
announced Man of Steel 2 103 in
basically the same conversation I wonder
how much of this is because of what the
Rock did with Henry Cavill was it a
domino you know I think it just I think
what happened here is he helped show
that you know maybe we didn't need to do
a whole reboot or a whole reset on the
DC Universe we just needed to kind of
refine a couple of things without being
like a race at all just start it all
over again freaking out man it's been a
while since everyone's made the world
with this nervous I have that's actually
Walter Hamada wrote that he's like I
don't know how to reboot everything I
think what happened with The Rock was he
kept hearing how much people like me
because we talked about it we're so
overjoyed and so overpowered I think he
just got proud papa bear energy like
when I see him like leak it he's always
just like like I think he just got
excited so I don't know if he ever meant
to but he's such a good businessman he's
such a good marketer there has to be a
part of his brain that's like this thing
that worked for me is going to work for
others I'm really proud of it okay I'm
gonna tell you well the original
post-credits scene if I'm not mistaken
was Superman was gonna show up but they
were gonna kind of do a Shazam thing
where you don't really see his face and
how that kind of carried over into
Peacemaker where there was a superman
but you don't see his face which is so
weird well they wanted to leave it open
and then Hollywood report order did I
don't know if you guys heard about it
but there was reports came out about
Walter Hamada well you know everyone's
favorite band Walter Ramada not wanting
Henry Cavill specifically to be in there
but Dwayne Johnson sort of went around
him went to uh the producers Deluca and
Abdi to give it the thumbs up and they
only shot this in September this is post
Comic-Con this was shot right before
Labor Day according to this article that
was just now that's nuts and that
explains so much because remember there
was a bit of a kind of a vitriolic
response in parts of the crowd with
Comic-Con when Dwayne Johnson came out
there and everyone was hyping up that
Henry Cavill is going to return he's
going to return physically there I
believed it I believed it and the way
Dwayne Johnson was sort of dancing
around it I've had my criticisms of of
the movie and I've had my uh opinions
about what the conversation was sort of
morphing like when it came to Dwayne
Johnson assuming like he has like this
unusual control over the DC films or at
least the ones he's involved with right
however knowing that this came out in
September knowing the way he reacts to
fans knowing the way he listens knowing
that man people really want Henry Cavill
Superman I gotta make sure this happens
because this is the one like this would
not have happened if it weren't for him
and I think that is so insanely awesome
that it was him listening to the fans
like I'm not a big fan of this movie but
damn do I respect the fact that he went
all out like that to get Henry Cavill
especially being in the crowd and you
know they have videos in a Comic Con
with some people booing when it came
talking about Superman he would dance
around the subject of it of like because
you know it hits you Superman that
conversation was already deep in play
and he was trying to get it done yeah
he's trying to get done this in
September that means when he's sitting
there in July he's going like I'm trying
like it is yeah
and I really respect the fact that even
after the movie comes out he's still so
wanting to know what that experience was
for us us I think there's a reason the
rock is this big of a staple of of the
movie entertainment world and the reason
he has so much control is I don't think
there's as many people as plugged in and
again this sounds like a Shameless name
drop but when I walked in the room to do
the interview he had seen our reactions
and knew who I was no one at his level
was 6.7 million followers or whatever on
Instagram does their own Instagram
except the rock like The Rock was the
one that like picked the screenshot and
sent it out because he knew this channel
that means he's that plugged into the
fans he's that invested in what people
wanted I need to reshoot might not
spoiler review dude Johnson's gonna
watch her wrestle
well it's only cropping and koi into his
montages and Sean and Greg aren't
included in those Instagram videos some
people were [ __ ] talking about the
non-spoiler review gotta be honest and
then Greg's like make sure koi doesn't
do a review because he liked it keep
that positivity off the real rejects
there's not other actors of his level
and producers of his level that are that
Hands-On because he made this happen
because he knew that's what people
wanted I mean this changes the DC
Universe like he single-handedly did
change the hierarchy power moves like
this is something beautiful because
knowing the journey and the build up how
it was like this forsaken Superman this
is so weird they're gonna do faceless
Castle again I know it's just like the
Superman and Henry Cavill was in
purgatory when I'm like this is kind of
strange how we're not doing anything
with it and it took Dwayne Johnson
fighting that's what's so weird is Henry
cavill's such a good Superman he clearly
loves the character the fans want it
those are the three ingredients you need
yes you want the actor to be invested
you want the fans to want it and you
want it to be the right casting Choice
which it clearly was it's very strange
that it took a another movie 14 years
after his movie or whatever it was to be
like no no he's back like that's a weird
that's unfortunate bizarre what's ever
happened in the history of any medium
well yeah I thought it was a beautiful
post-credits scene The Rock has been you
know kind of a little bit unclear of
where he thinks the direction should go
after this it's like obviously he wants
a Black Adam versus Superman movie like
obviously he wants that to happen is
that the next movie we don't know we
have no idea Shazam should probably
interact with like Adam at some point
yeah I mean it's like do you hop
immediately to Black Adam versus uh
Superman or do you do one in between
this Black Adam versus Shazam I would do
Shazam 3 with Black Adam as the villain
that'd be cool like I would call it
Shazam 3 had blackout in the villain
that way you get one more movie to fall
in love with this take on Black Adam
because you know a lot of times when you
got that big conflict movie you want to
be established in the character so you
make Black Adam the antagonist that'll
further you know solidify him as the
anti-hero then you do a Superman versus
a Black Adam movie yeah all right guys
what are your thoughts leave them down
below follow koi on Tick Tock subscribe
click that Bell leave a like catch you
all soon
[Music]